>> Martha: A DEMOCRAT WHO IS
THE HEAD OF A PROCLAIMED
SANCTUARY CITY BLASTING HIS OWN
PARTY OVER THE BORDER CRISIS.
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
UNDER A LOT OF PRESSURE TO DEAL
WITH THE NEARLY 10,000 MIGRANTS
HAVE BEEN BUSED IN FROM THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
ADAM'S INITIAL SOLUTION WAS TO
BUILD A TENT CITY IN AOC'S
DISTRICT IN THE BRONX TO HOUSE
THEM.
SHE DIDN'T LIKE THAT TOO MUCH.
OCASIO-CORTEZ VOICED HER CONCERN
THAT IT WAS IN A FLOOD ZONE.
ADAMS CAVED TO HER DEMANDS AND
OUTS BEING MOVED A FEW MILES
AWAY.
THE MIRROR CALLING OUT BOTH
SIDES OVER THIS CRISIS.
>> THE FAR RIGHT IS DOING THE
WRONG THING IN THE FAR LEFT IS
DOING NOTHING.
EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE IN THIS
GAME.
EVERYONE SHOULD BE ON ALL HANDS
ON DECK.
EVERYONE.
NOT SIT BACK THROWING ROCKS.
A ROCK IS NOT A PLAN.
EVERYONE SHOULD BE ON DECK
HELPING THIS CRISES RIGHT NOW.
>> Martha: OKAY, JANINE, LET
ME START WITH YOU.
I REMEMBER
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ GOING
TO THE BORDER AND SHE WAS
PRACTICALLY IN TEARS ABOUT THE
TOILETS THAT WERE SINKS, RIGHT?
NOW SHE IS THE MISTRESS OF
NIMBY.
SHE IS LIKE "NOT IN MY
BACKYARD."
I AM SO BLOWN AWAY BY THE
HYPOCRISY OF THE STORY.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, NEW YORK.
STAND BY WHAT YOU SAY.
IF YOU BELIEVE THESE PEOPLE ARE
MISTREATED, YOU SHOULD BE
ROLLING OUT THE RED CARPET IN
THE BRONX AND MAKING SURE THAT
YOU'RE TAKING EXCELLENT CARE OF
THEM.
>> Jeanine: THAT'S WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT IN THE
A BLOCK.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE HYPOCRITES
WHO ARE LIKE, WE ALL LOVE THE
IMMIGRANTS.
DON'T YOU DARE BRING THEM TO THE
BRONX.
DON'T YOU DARE BRING THEM TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
BY THE WAY, THE ONES COMING TO
NEW YORK CITY THAT MAYOR ADAMS
IS COMPLAINING ABOUT ARE COMING
FROM A DEMOCRAT CITY IN TEXAS
FROM A DEMOCRAT MAYOR SENDING
THEM TO NEW YORK CITY.
YOU DON'T HEAR ADAMS COMPLAINING
ABOUT HIM, WHO IS SENT MORE THAN
GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
YOU ONLY HEAR GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
THIS IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
IT'S ALL ABOUT AND IDEOLOGY.
WE WANT THE POWER.
WANT THE ABILITY TO GET AN
OFFICE SO THEREFORE WE WILL
BE --
WE WILL BE SILENT BECAUSE THEY
WILL VOTE FOR US.
EDUCATION, MEDICATION, HOUSING.
WE WILL GIVE THEM A PHONE,
HOUSING.
WHENEVER THEY NEED TO BE
AMERICANS.
WE ARE GOING TO SHAKE THEIR HAND
WHEN THEY SHOW UP.
BUT DON'T YOU DARE, DON'T YOU
DARE ASK SOMEONE IN THE MILITARY
TO NOT BE VACCINATED.
WE WILL SHAKE YOUR HAND IF
YOU'RE COMING IN FROM THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> Martha: PEOPLE GETTING OFF
THE BOSS AND THE HANDSHAKES IN
THE GOETTA PACKAGE.
GOING TO PUT YOU IN A TENT.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO BE PUSHING.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DO ON THE
ISLAND?
PEOPLE PLAY BASEBALL, SOCCER,
IT'S FULL OF PLAYGROUNDS AND
FIELDS.
APPARENTLY THIS IS WHERE THE
MIGRANTS ARE GOING TO BE LIVING.
>> Jesse: RANDALL'S ISLAND ON
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
NOT ONLY DO THEY HAVE SPORTS
FACILITIES FOR YOUNG KIDS, THEY
HAVE A WASTEWATER TREATMENT
FACILITY AND INSANE ASYLUM.
NOW THEY ARE ADDING A TENT CITY
FOR MIGRANTS AND AOC'S IS NOT IN
MY BACKYARD.
MAYBE IF SHE HADN'T KILLED
100,000 JOBS FROM AMAZON THEY
MIGHT'VE HAD SOMETHING TO DO FOR
WORK.
SHE DOESN'T WANT IT THERE BUT
SHE DOESN'T HAVE A PLAN EITHER,
SO WHAT IS THE PLAN?
FREEZING ILLEGALS ON AN ISLAND
IN A COUPLE MONTHS TRYING TO
ESCAPE INTO THE EAST RIVER?
RECOVER THEM AND PULLED HIM BACK
IN?
HOW IS THAT SANE?
NANCY WANTS TO SEND THEM TO
FLORIDA AND PICK CROPS.
IS THAT LEGAL?
I THOUGHT YOU WEREN'T SUPPOSED
TO HIRE ILLEGALS.
NOW NANCY SAYS YOU CAN.
JOE DOESN'T HAVE A PLAN.
YOU CAN'T SAY ANYONE WHO LEGALLY
COMES ACROSS THE BORDER IS AN
ASYLUM SEEKER NOT HAVE A SYSTEM
IN PLACE TO SUCTION UP THE
ENTIRE SOUTHERN HEMISPHERE,
SOUTH AMERICA, INTO OUR COUNTRY,
THERE IS NO PLAN IN PLACE FOR
THIS SYSTEM.
>> Martha: IF IT'S AT
SANCTUARY CITY, SHOULDN'T WE
HAVE A PROGRAM WHETHER SOME KIND
OF TEMPORARY EMPLOYMENT OR
SOMETHING?
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO AND IT'S
GOING TO GET UGLY QUICKLY.
>> Harold: I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT, THE WAY THAT YOU LEAD AND
WAS SPOT ON.
THE PERSON WHO FRAMED IT RIGHT
WAS THE MIRROR.
REPUBLICANS ARE GREAT DOERS.
DEMOCRATS ARE MISSING IN ACTION
AND ARE IN DENIAL.
OUR VICE PRESIDENT WHO IS IN
CHARGE OF THIS, IF SHE HAS A
PLAN, SHE'S NOT SHARING IT WITH
ANYBODY.
I HAVE SAID FOR A LONG TIME.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT SCREAMS
OUT FOR A SOLUTION AND IT'S ONE
WE COULD PROBABLY DEVELOP AROUND
THIS DAY, THE GREAT CHALLENGES.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN HONEST AND
TRANSPARENT SYSTEM FOR THE WAY
PEOPLE HAVE A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
PEOPLE WHO SPEND TEN, 12, 14
YEARS, THEY RESENT THIS PERHAPS
MORE THAN SOME AROUND THIS
TABLE.
WE NEED TO STREAMLINE THE ASYLUM
PROCESS.
WE SHOULD MAKE IT CLEAR IT IS
BECOME YOU CAME WITH A STORY
ABOUT HOW THINGS ARE BAD IN YOUR
COUNTRY DOES NOT QUALIFY YOU TO
STAY HERE AND WAIT SIX MONTHS
FOR HEARING.
THAT NEEDS TO BE TIGHTENED UP.
THREE, BUILD A WALL.
BUILD A WALL.
REPUBLICANS WILL CAPITULATE.
YOU HAVE TO CAPITULATE ON OTHER
THINGS.
PUT MORE LAW ENFORCEMENT THERE.
YOU HAVE TO INVEST IN THIS
HEMISPHERE.
WEATHER, DRUGS, YOU'VE WRECKED
THE HEMISPHERE THAT'S RIGHT IN
OUR OWN BACKYARD.
YOU CAN ONLY EXPECT AND IMAGINE
BECAUSE WE ARE THE GREATEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD, GREATEST
FREEDOM, RULE OF LAW,
OPPORTUNITY, INGENUITY, SPORTS,
FOOD.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WANT TO COME
HERE SO WE HAVE TO MAKE IT WHERE
THEIR HOME, THEIR LAND AS
ATTRACTIVE AS WELL.
THIS IS A PROBLEM SCREAMING OUT
FOR A SOLUTION.
IT'S RIGHT BEFORE US IF EVERYONE
PUT THE POLITICS ASIDE AND DO IT
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> Martha: THAT HAS TO BE A
PROCESS TO GET THE COUNTRY.
BEFORE YOU CAN HAVE THESE
COMPETING THOUGHTS.
I'M EXTERNALLY PRO-IMMIGRANT.
WE SELF SELECT FOR REALLY
INTERESTING PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE
WHO RISK THEIR LIVES TO COME
HERE.
IT'S PART OF THE AMERICAN GENE.
HAVING SAID THAT, PART OF THE
AMERICAN GENE'S RESPECT FOR A
LINE.
EVEN IMMIGRANTS WHEN THEY COME
HERE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH LINE
CUTTERS.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SLOWLY LEARNING.
THEY MAY BE BETTING ON THE WRONG
HORSE IN TERMS OF FUTURE VOTES
WHEN IMMIGRANTS COME HERE AND
EMBRACE THE AMERICAN SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE, ORDER, CIVIL SOCIETY,
ALL THE THINGS THAT THE HARD
LEFT WANT TO ABANDON.
YOU CAN FIND A LOCAL MEXICAN.
I'M SORRY.
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY HARD,
RIGHT?
THERE'S GOING TO BE NO
VENEZUELANS WHO WANT GRADE
SCHOOL TEACHERS TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THEIR SEX LIFE.
IT AIN'T GOING TO HAPPEN.
I AM UPSET THAT YOU SAID
MISTRESS OF NAME B.
THAT IS THE BEST LINE I'VE EVER
HEARD THAT IT MAKES ME VERY
ANGRY THAT I DIDN'T COP WITH IT.
NEW YORK POLITICIANS SHOULD BE
ECSTATIC THAT THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THIS.
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE THE STATUE
OF LIBERTY AND IF THEY AREN'T.
AOC IS ACTUALLY MORE
ANTI-IMMIGRANT THAN THE PEOPLE
SHE CLAIMS IS RACIST BECAUSE SHE
DIDN'T WANT THEM IN HER
BACKYARD.
IT'S PRETTY AMAZING TO ME.
THE JUDGE IS RIGHT.
THERE IS A LOT OF OVERLAP HERE.
IF ANY SOLUTIONS COME FROM
PEOPLE LIKE US, IT'S GOING TO BE
DEEMED ANTI-COMPASSIONATE.
MEANWHILE THE BORDER CAUSES
HUNDREDS OF DEATHS AND ILLNESSES
AND RAPES.
BUT WE ARE THE ONES WHO LACK
COMPASSION.
IT'S THE SAME PROBLEM.
IT DEPENDS ON WHERE IT COMES
FROM.
PEOPLE HAVE TO LET GO OF THEIR
EGO AND THE TRIBALISM OF THEIR
OWN PARTY IN ORDER TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
WE MIGHT BE TOO FAR GONE.
>> Jesse: IF I CAN LET GO OF
MY EGO, ANYONE CAN.
>> Martha: COMING UP,
COAST GUARD MEMBERS WHO PUT
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO SAVE
OTHERS DURING HURRICANE IN AND
ARE CONGRATULATED BY PRESIDE